the wage gap separating men and women is
much wider than previously thought
according to a revealing new report the
Institute for Women's policy research
claims women earned just 49 cents for
each dollar that was paid to a man for
over a 15-year span that's a big
difference from census data that show
women make 80 cents for each dollar a
man earns CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is with us to explain this
is a really eye-opening report Jill so
the census looks back over a year this
new report looks back over 15 years and
what did it find and that's an important
difference because that takes into
account that women take breaks from
their career much more often than men in
fact over those 15 years women are only
working full time 28% of the time
compared with 59% for men and this
clearly from the report is showing that
this is because women are most
disproportionately affected by caring
for their kids caring for their parents
and that takes them out of the workforce
as a result when we look at these 15
years we are seeing the wage gap blow
out it's actually pretty astounding and
we know that even women who are staying
in for the whole 15 years are still
making less talk about that because not
everyone takes time off to have a family
over those 15 years they're still
effective yeah this is a fascinating
statistic from the report so women who
stay in the labor force for the 15 years
compared to women who take just a year
off the women who take a year off make
39% less than the women who are working
for the entire time so there are other
things going on and obviously this is
one of those reports where you say well
okay great now what yeah well Nora and I
were talking about this off camera
because the onus always seems to be on
women but what can women do when they
see this report to change this this is
really hard because as a financial
planner I used to always try to say to
my clients way back when you've got to
really argue to get the best benefit and
pay package as quickly as you can so
early in your career I know it's hard
but you've got to practice and you've
got to really review these benefits the
other thing you have to do is you have
to continue to advocate for yourself
this is very important because we know
from many sir
women argue very well to get raises for
the people who work for them but not for
themselves and which is crazy we also
want women to take advantage of
retirement planning as early as possible
so while you are working or maybe you
have a company match put money away and
if you can squeeze out even a few
dollars even when you're not working and
obviously CEOs have a role to play in
this as well yeah I mean this is about
creating a benefit structure that is
more friendly to families and we know
that that is a key so that could be
enhanced family leave that could be more
subsidize a subsidizing of childcare and
the reality is that the u.s. is really
what lagging behind the rest of the
world on this we are the only developed
nation that doesn't mandate paid
maternity leave clearly we have a lot of
work to do Jill thank you so much